thank you very much dear prime minister
the Alexander
Mr tase
Mrs albas
Mr felcher
Mr Clarke ladies and gentlemen
distinguished guests
thank you very much for giving me indeed
the honor of addressing you tonight
and as you said Belgium has a very
special place in my heart I was born
here in Excel I went to school in UCLA
um so many many wonderful childhood
memories
but of course Belgium also has a very
special place in Europe
it is a country of creatives and
innovators
in fact in preparation for tonight
I learned how much Belgium innovators
helped shape the modern world plastic
for example synthetic rubber
the engine
as felt
the electric tram modern drugs and even
the World Wide Web all these miraculous
inventions can be traced back in some
form to Belgian ingenuity
today
the next big innovation is taking shape
in the North Sea
around about 45 kilometers off the
Belgian Coast
the world's first energy Island
it will link Belgium to an offshore wind
farms Network
spanning the entire North Sea
construction is set to begin next year
supported by the European investment
through next Generation EU
it is part of Belgium's plan to increase
its offshore wind capacity to six
gigawatt by 2030 and 8 gigawatt by 2040
these are
sober figures but to give you a picture
this would be enough to power all
Belgian households
so the north Seas rapidly becoming
becoming Europe's clean and affordable
power station
not only
will it help us
to get rid of Russian fossil fuels
homegrown Renewables will also power the
world's next Industrial Revolution made
right here in Belgium and made in Europe
and this is what I would like to speak
about today
the next decades
will see the greatest industrial
transformation of our times
we in Europe have been Front Runners
for years with the European green deal
as you know we cast our 2050 Net Zero
Target into law
that provided predictability
and transparency to businesses
we backed it up with the investment
Firepower of an 800 billion Euro
investment plan Next Generation EU
and today clean tech is the fastest
growing investment sector in Europe
doubling its value
in 2021 alone
but as we enter 2023
indeed Europe's cleantech industry faces
a collision of old and new challenges
and of course the most serious is
Russia's War and the higher energy costs
not only is Putin waging a war against
Ukraine's integrity
and freedom
but also against Europe's energy
economy
and democracy
a year ago only a year ago Europe had a
massive dependency on Russian fossil
fuels of course built over decades
and this made us very vulnerable to
Russia's blackmail
so indeed as you said we had to deal
with a scenario of potential blackouts
and power shortages
you remember that the prices for gas
were skyrocketing in summer
but today
we got rid of this dangerous dependency
we replaced over 80 percent of Russian
Pipeline gas in less than eight months
and this would not have been possible
without for example the LNG terminal in
the port of antwerbrugge
the European people
saved 20 of their energy demand it was
them they understood it
we introduced indeed the gas price cap
one of the topics you insisted on
rightly so Alexander and the global oil
price cap
and then this is the most important in
the whole picture
we doubled the additional deployment of
Renewables we made it no blackouts no
power shortages
we made it to diversify completely away
from Russia towards our friends and new
resources
SO gas prices are today lower
than they were at the beginning of the
war
however
the year ahead will be still challenging
and indeed it was just set
the gas prices or Energy prices compared
to the United States are still higher
here in the European Union the cost of
doing business is rising because of
inflation
and it will take a few more years before
large amounts of homegrown and cheap
wind energy become an advantage for the
Belgian economy
and at the same time
we all see that International
competition
is ident is intensifying and getting
tougher
I think a clean tech race is in full
swing
we see that the largest economies in the
world from the United States to India
from China to Japan they have all
started
to invest massively in the green
innovation
that's good
this can be only good news for our
planet
but it is of course a lot of pressure
on our own clean transition
and it is Will imperil our own clean
transition
if the Level Playing Field is not given
we need a global Level Playing Field
and we need a European Level Playing
Field for our economy
and indeed the Alexander
you have consistently
and rightly so argued
that Belgium businesses
and I say European businesses indeed
feel the heat
so we must get better at nurturing our
own industry
that is necessary for the clean
transition
and that is from hydrogen
to chemicals
from biotech to nanotech
and it is to achieve this goal
that I have announced that we need a
green deal
industrial plan for Europe
it is our plan for Europe to secure our
place
as the home of industrial Innovation and
cleantech
our green deal industrial plan will
cover four pillars key pillars
first of all indeed I would like to
speak about the regulatory environment
and it was mentioned
second Point financing
third pillar skills
and fourth pillar trade
our first pillar is about speed and
access
we need to create a regulatory
environment and you said it rightly so
that allows us to scale up fast in
sectors that are so crucial to reaching
Net Zero
for that we will propose and deliver by
mid-march
The Net Zero industry Act
think for example of hydrogen
a technology where Belgium is said to be
a world leader
The Net Zero industry act can be a game
changer
and hydrogen is in it
we need to urgently now move for example
the hydrogen economy from niche to scale
we have doubled our targets for 2034
hydrogen that is we say 10 million tons
we want to produce ourselves in the
European Union
and another 10 million tons of hydrogen
we want to import
each year
by that we identify clear goals for the
European clean tech sector by 2030.
the example was hydrogen because we all
know
only what gets measured gets done
this
NetZero industry act will of course also
go far beyond the goals that we set
ourselves
but it will go also into permitting I
hear you whenever you talk to me you say
permitting procedures are too slow get
faster we want to create an overall
conducive environment and I know if we
want to unleash our potential we need to
have less red tape we need to work more
integrated so we're happy to take any
kind of advice and proposal how we can
be faster more precise better and
Slimmer if I may say so in the
regulatory environment that sometimes
puts puts so much burden on your
shoulders
The Net Zero industry act will also go
hand in hand with our critical raw
materials Act
and here you know that
the axis of European business
to critical raw materials is vital for
our clean transition
and Europe is still way too vulnerable
what that is concerned take for example
Rare Earth
Europe is 98 dependent if it comes to
from one country
and you all know it that is China
so part of the solution has to do with
very Strategic investment here in Europe
I was very happy when we were in kiruna
in Sweden the good news of the finding
of the largest field of rare Earths and
critical raw materials ever in the
European Union
so we need to invest to improve the
refining the processing and the
recycling of raw materials inside our
European Union
but let's not fool ourselves we also
need
to face the very simple truth
that Europe cannot become totally
self-reliant for many raw materials
so
we must work with our trade partners
to de-risk our supply chains
and a possible solution here is
to build a critical raw materials club
and miss your Tice
you thought about that with our friends
and partners a critical raw materials
Club so that we have reliable Supply
chains and strong Supply chains among
like-minded Partners from the United
States to Ukraine actually
this is the whole first pillar about
speed and access
the second pillar of our plan is to
boost investment
in our cleantech industry
for years now
China's subsidies were twice as high
as those of the European Union relative
to the GDP
and now
China has made subsidizing cleantech
Innovation and Manufacturing
a key priority in its Five-Year Plan
and of course
open economies are also stepping up
to support their clean tech industry
indeed let's look at the United States
and the inflation reduction Act
don't get me wrong
I know that our clean tech sector is
competitive
we are world leader
and even in our relatively high energy
price environment we're getting along
but if on top now
comes the subsidies abroad this is too
much and these are unleveling the
playing field and this is why we will
indeed propose to temporarily
very targeted
will adapt our stated rules
easier calculations simpler procedures
accelerated approvals that must be the
goal
let's not forget
we have world class leading research and
development like iMac for example here
in Belgium
that is very attractive for attractive
for investors
but we need more to create the necessary
for example chips ecosystem in Europe
that's
our European ships act mobilizes
billions of investment for development
and mass production of Next Generation
ships
and this kind of
strategic Focus that we had with the
chips Act
we now need
on our industry
that is necessary for reaching Net Zero
let me give you another example it's the
chemicals industry it was mentioned
tonight already
the port of antever Bruges is the
largest cluster of the chemical industry
in Europe
and the second largest worldwide after
Houston
chemicals chemical products represent
nearly 10 percent of our European
exports
and to need to reach Net Zero our goals
we need our chemicals industry on board
here in the European Union and
competitive
it is competitive
since 1990 Europe increased the chemical
production by nearly 50 percent
at the same time greenhouse gas emission
in that sector decreased over 50 percent
so this is clean innovation made in
Belgium that we need to keep in Europe
and therefore
access and speed
stated
but this is only one side of the coin if
you take stated we also know that state
eight
is potentially if it's only given
unleveling or fragmenting our single
Market
So to avoid the fragmentation of our
single marking Market we also have to
give the other side of the coin and that
is Step Up EU funding fast targeted
precise
we're working now
on a bridging solution
to provide immediate and very targeted
support where it is most needed
we have already the legislative vehicle
speed it's called repower EU
and for the longer term we are working
on a European sovereignty fund that will
be the structural solution for Upstream
research Innovation and strategic
industrial projects that are key for our
Net Zero industry
the first regulatory environment the
second funding the third pillar is about
skills
the best technology is only as good as
the people who know how to use it
and I know how much you're looking for
qualified Personnel skilled workers
and indeed we must take advantage of the
full potential that we have here
first of all good news
the European unemployment rate is at six
percent
that's incredibly low
but I'm aware of the fact that it
already camouflages
partially
the lack of skilled Personnel that you
have
and there is potential we can get better
what the skills are concerned I said
unemployment rate is six percent
youth unemployment on average in the
European Union
is at 14 what a waste of talent
female participation in the labor force
labor force is 69 percent
male participation is at 80 percent
what an amount of untapped potential
make it possible
actually this is also true for older
workers
there is a saying which I really like
because all the workers have experience
and wisdom
and that saying goes the younger workers
may run faster but the older ones know
the shortcut
so there's a lot of wisdom and potential
out there that we could recruit
if we now invest massively
into
the clean growth
all member states must pay attention to
the topic of upskilling and that is why
I welcome the Belgium initiative that is
investing massively in its people with
the support of Next Generation EU
for example you're upgrading digital
education and Flemish School just the
right way to go
you are building a new biotech campus in
Charlotte
to offer vocational training in a
cutting-edge sector that's exactly what
we need
High skilled workers are key to our
Global competitiveness
that is why we made this year
a priority
with a European year of skills knowing
that without that the people we will
never make it but with them we have an
enormous chance to stay world leader
finally
the fourth pillar of the green deal
industrial plan
is to facilitate open and fair trade for
the benefit of all
and this is something I know belgians
know
I remember indeed during the pandemic
the Temptation and the pressure
was huge
to close the borders and to stop export
we resisted and Alexander You supported
me massively in that we resisted the
pressure and the Temptation we stayed
open
and indeed this pays off no because now
because we were the only region
worldwide that stayed open and business
does keep that in mind
so facilitate open and fair trade
for the benefit of all that is create
new economies of scale
common standards and more resilient
Supply chains
our answer is not protectionism but a
more ambitious trade agenda
ladies and gentlemen
all across the globe
the label
made in Europe
represents quality
and Europe's industrial leaders many of
whom are here based in Belgium
really can be proud of this
but made in Europe means so much more
it means that a given product
comes from a place
where we protect the environment
and where workers earn a decent wage
that it comes from a continent
we're cutting at Edge research is done
where students can attend University
independent of their parents income
made in Europe
this is also a statement about Who We
Are
a diverse continent
full of creativity
a continent where entrepreneurs can
thrive
and no one is Left Behind
and this increasingly
plays a fundamental role
when companies decide where to do
business
because there are many interesting
places in the world where you can earn a
good money
but when it comes to Social Security
if you're old
or sick
or in need
when it comes to attracting the right
people
with the right skills
when it comes to accessing one single
prosperous Market
of 450 million consumers
there is no better place than Europe
and therefore Long Live Europe thank you
very much
you can speak with us yes
thank you very much